damit kann meine lieben freunde wisst ja
alle dass sich erdkunde leistungskurs im
abi hatte auf gymnasium damals deswegen
ist das heutige video wie für mich
gemacht denn wir spielen endlich mal
wieder den geo gestern beim geo cacher
geht es darum dass wir auf irgend eine
straße irgendwo auf der welt geschmissen
werden und sagen müssen wo wir uns
gerade befinden
das sieht auch wie meine wohnung gar
nicht allerdings erdkunde leistungskurs
hatte weiß ich natürlich direkte wie wir
uns hier orientieren können da schauen
wir ziemlich zuallererst einmal die
schilder an der stätte
200 meter ok in 200 metern ist der
tankstelle anhand der preise können wir
dann definitiv erst mal erkennen wie
hier die e sieht
dass griechenland nur die hand so ein
komisches ohne zum stock drin als
nächstes schauen wir uns nun mal die
kennzeichen hier vorne an da gehe ich
nicht einfach mal hier rum und kann nun
ran summen überhaupt nichts erkennen
also noch einen kleinen schritt wieder
zurück von hier dann ran suchen und wir
sehen dass wir auch hier nichts erkennen
können fahren war allerdings die straße
hier erst mal so ein bisschen weiter in
richtung stadt hier hin da sind wir
jetzt hier vorne angekommen und da haben
wir auch schon den nächsten hinweis denn
hier sind flaggen das sind
blumen hier vorne haben wir auch noch
ein schild dasteht hotel plaza palace
swimmingpool und poolbar und hier haben
wir flaggen wir haben einmal eine
europaflagge das heißt sie sind
definitiv irgendwo in europa und das
sieht wirklich eine griechenland-frage
sein ich kann jetzt natürlich ganz genau
erraten wo wir in griechenland hier sind
aber auf jeden fall im landesinneren
weil hier nirgendwo irgendwo mehr zu
sehen dass deswegen können jetzt einfach
mal hier gucken und nach griechenland
gehen wir wissen ja griechenland ist
hier und ich würde einfach mal sagen wir
befinden uns hier irgendwo im
landesinneren wir geben das ganze jetzt
ab und wir sind hat
200 40 kilometer aber weiter hoffen
insel nächste runde meine lieben freunde
wir sind irgendwo an einem
flughafen
glaube ich nicht
das sind keine flugzeuge sondern lkw ist
aber auch egal denn wir haben hier auf
jeden fall eine riesige firma und anhand
der schilder kommen erstmal sie ins
center lane n das wird vermutlich
amerika sein weil wir auch hier gelbe
linien haben die das ja alles trennen
die wenigsten wissen ja dass ich erkunde
leistungskurs im abitur hatte deswegen
schauen wir auch hier erstmals ganz kurz
uns die kennzeichen an da sehen wir
nämlich auch direkt das hier der seinen
seitenspiegel
verloren gucken wir mal hier vorne auf
die kennzeichen da sehen wir nämlich
dass die alle zensiert sind aber solche
karin wie seinem dodge ram oder sowas
das wird nur in amerika gefahren jetzt
müssen wir natürlich allerdings erstmal
gucken wo wir uns befinden könnten
commerce die fünf business park ok die
fights sind wir wahrscheinlich schauen
wir mal so ein bisschen ob wir hier
eventuell doch das ein oder andere
gebäude erkennen können und ob sich hier
vielleicht jetzt irgendwie eine kirche
oder so befindet die haben wir hier das
ist nämlich die
harmonie christchurch da weiß ich ganz
genau wo wir sind wir sind nämlich genau
hier in new york da war ich nämlich mal
und wir befinden uns in atlanta
da ich allerdings eher leistungskurs im
abi hatte werde ich das nächste
definitiv verraten habe finden wir uns
jetzt nämlich hier irgendwo das ist eine
ziemlich abgegrenzte straßen das ist
einfach ein feldweg und hier vorne ist
auch nur ein wohnhaus wir haben hier als
hinweise bisher nichts das schild kann
man auch nicht erkennen es könnte
deutschland sein sieht aber auch er so
ein bisschen auf grund der ganzen natur
und äpfel bäumen und so vielleicht auch
nach italien toskana aus wenn sich hier
vorne auch dieser häuser anguckt das
wird jetzt auch jetzt erstmal unser ziel
sein dass wir uns hier vorne so ein
bisschen die natur angucken wie kommen
wir nicht weiter hier kommen wir weiter
in diesem weg es könnte tatsächlich ital
sein oder spanien ich tendiere gerade
noch zu seiner mitte italien grenzt ja
in spanien an
von daher würde ich sagen dass wir
gleich irgendwie die mitte nehmen ich
kann das jetzt noch nicht so richtig
beurteilen allerdings können wir hier
noch einmal ein bisschen straßenschilder
anschauen es könnte auch deutschland
seine ist es nicht das ist die neue
warte wie ging nochmal so ticken weiter
vor und schauen uns mal dieses schild
hier an da steht firma da
das ist spanien ja das ist
hier
ja wie gesagt italien hier befinden wir
uns jetzt definitiv wieder irgendwo in
amerika würde ich sagen das ist doch
ziemlich klar weil wir direkt in amerika
flagge haben das ist aber immer ein
bisschen doof weil das land ein bisschen
größer ist ich persönlich habe ich
allerdings erdkunde lka damals auf
gymnasium von daher kann ich euch auch
hier direkt sagen wo wir uns befinden
wir haben hier große landschaft das
heißt es wird auf jeden fall nicht new
york sein oder irgendwie so das wetter
sieht auch sehr schön dass ich denke mal
das wird irgendwo in der mitte
beziehungsweise im südlichen teil von
amerika sein ich habe auf welche vorne
vielleicht irgendeinen schild finden wo
der staat darauf steht das kann uns
allerdings lange umgucken glaube ich
hier sieht auch ein bisschen nach
deutschland aus irgendwie somit den
bauernhöfen und den ganzen maisfeldern
und so irgendwie kommen ja auch nicht so
richtig voran und es braut sich auch
nichts weiteres auf mich schauen wir
einmal kurz links den hof an da sieht
man allerdings fast gar nichts
vielleicht hier irgendwie ne da steht
nur becks
wir sind uns alle einig dass wir uns
irgendwo in amerika befinden und
aufgrund der temperaturen würde ich
vielleicht sogar sagen so
colorado
das hier ist nun allerdings auch schon
die letzte runde meiner lieben freunde
wir sehen hier vorne menge palmen das
könnte vielleicht auf ein
okay davon haben wir auch einen schilder
schauen wir uns mal von hier vorne an
das könnte eventuell auf irgendetwas
spanisches in deutschland hier sehen wir
auch schon murat angab das ist auf jeden
fall irgendwas in spanien von da her da
ich ja auch erdkunde lka hatte kann ich
euch direkt sagen dhabi plantation ja
das sieht sehr sehr krasser spanien aus
sie haben wir denn king plant okay sind
plantagen und 2000 sofort die fahren
jedoch alle auf der linken seite
in spanien fährt man nicht links und das
weiß ich auch nur weil ich erdkunde lk
damals hatte wir haben hier ein schild
mit
beruht
auf grund meiner das erdkunde
leistungskurs offen gymnasium kann ich
euch sagen dass das wahrscheinlich
thailand sein wird jetzt müsste ich nur
wissen wo sich thailand befindet wir
haben hier vorne afghanistan indien
thailand okay hier vorne ich denke mal
dass wir wenn der plantagen sind wir uns
er irgendwie in solchen grünen regionen
befinden hier unten jetzt nicht so
unbedingt aber vielleicht irgendwo hier
das könnte richtig sein wird für
professional
kilometer
ich bin nicht so schlecht und wisst ihr
warum ehrlich damals auf einem gymnasium
erdkunde leistungskurs hat so
ist wissen die wenigsten
an der stelle wird das heute wieder ist
allerdings auch werden wieder die
freunde wenn euch endlich mal wieder
georg esser mit mir
gut gefallen hat dann lasst doch gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video
abonniert main kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr weitere videos nicht
verpassen wollt habt ihr bock auf einen
weiteren teil geo gestern schreibt in
die kommentare oder generell wenn ihr
video idee was ich mal wieder hochladen
soll dann schreibt auch und in die
kommentare und wir
[Musik]